[Musica]
[Applauso]
Guardate queste tre immagini
nella prima riconosciamo la regina delle
influencer che ha indossato questo abito
a Sanremo un abito firmato da un
importante Maison di moda che lanciava
un messaggio femminista di
autodeterminazione del corpo delle donne
la seconda invece attratta dalla
campagna pubblicitaria di un grosso
Brand internazionale
che per il lancio di una collezione in
edizione limitata ha voluto utilizzare
questi motivi ultra colorati come ode
all'arte Audace alla creatività infinita
e al divertimento
l'ultima invece è un è tratta da un
frame del Fashion show di un noto
marchio italiano
dove i modelli le modelle indossavano
dei degli abiti ispirati alla eleganza
senza tempo al fascino discreto e al
minimalismo genderless con Toni come
potete vedere pacati e rassicuranti
in tutte queste tre circostanze è
successo qualcosa di molto particolare
in ciascuna di Esse infatti Fateci caso
è presente un riferimento alla storia
dell'arte che però è stato utilizzato a
mio avviso in maniera un po' impropria
l'abito dell'imprenditrice digitale cita
apertamente le antropometrie dell'epoca
blu una serie di quadri realizzati dal
grandissimo artista il clan a partire
dal 1958
coprendo di vernice blu i corpi di
alcune modelle che venivano poi fatte
adagiare su grandi tele bianche stese
per terra oppure appesi alle pareti
le modelle non erano libere di muoversi
nello spazio o di esprimersi liberamente
ma anzi erano da lui definite Living
brushes cioè pennelli viventi comandati
da lui a distanza Cioè era lui che
letteralmente
ordinava loro quali azioni intraprendere
la silhouette blu che vedete non è
neanche nel lavoro dell'artista
un'indagine sul corpo femminile anzi
era la testimonianza di un passaggio di
un'esistenza che supera la morte questo
perché da amante del Giappone qual era
l'idea gli venne osservando l'impronta
che un corpo Lascia sul materasso dopo
un match di judo e probabilmente anche
dopo aver visto l'ombra sulla pietra di
un uomo carbonizzato dalla bomba atomica
ad Hiroshima Insomma il femminismo c'è
tra poco
qui la borsa è stata realizzata in
collaborazione con l'artista yayoi
kusama
nella sua pratica la ripetizione
estenuante di pois è una forma di
autoterapia dai disturbi ossessivo
compulsivi che aveva maturato a seguito
di traumi infantili molto gravi e per
colpa dei quali lei è tuttora da 40 anni
vive all'interno di un ospedale
psichiatrico
sono quindi una forma di trasposizione
visiva del dolore Il Brand a partire da
questi elementi decorativi ha
addirittura sviluppato dei filtri Social
con i quali invitava gli utenti
accusa ignificare il proprio mondo Cioè
a guardarlo attraverso gli occhi di
kusama
Forse però il mondo di kusama non era
proprio così divertente come Il Brand
vorrebbe farci credere
e infine arriviamo la sfilata qua la
situazione un po' diversa rispetto a
quelle che vi ho finora descritto perché
l'arte non viene usata come una fonte di
ispirazione Ma come una scenografia
Infatti i modelli e le modelle
passeggiavano tra i sette palazzi
celesti di hanselm kiefer
un'installazione monumentale esposta
all'interno di uno spazio di arte
contemporanea a Milano e composta da
gigantesche torri di cemento armato che
evocano un paesaggio apocalittico
costituito dalle rovine dell'umanità
dagli orrori della seconda guerra
mondiale delle dittature e del
dell'olocausto
l'arte dell'artista tedesco è molto
violenta profondamente anti minimale
distante dall'armonia di cui parlava Il
Brand
questi sono solo alcuni esempi che ho
selezionato Perché i nomi degli Artisti
iniziano tutti con la k
Scherzo ovviamente
me ne sono accorta dopo ormai avevo
finito la presentazione quindi è
puramente casuale ma in realtà li ho
selezionati perché tra i più recenti
sono quelli che mi hanno colpita di più
ma in realtà ce ne sarebbero tantissimi
altri
praticamente è successo che i Brand
hanno preso dalle opere d'arte citate
soltanto l'aspetto più superficiale
l'aspetto per l'appunto cioè i codici
formali gli elementi estetici
interpretando male o forse manipolando
volutamente i messaggi originali delle
opere che sono stati epurati di tutte le
asperità e le controversie al fine di
poterci attaccare sopra i propri
messaggi commerciali
Questo è un approccio retinico che
esprime Una tendenza piuttosto diffusa
da parte
delle aziende del settore
affermarsi a una lettura puramente
visiva dell'oggetto artistico però non è
un atteggiamento nuovo e per coglierne
le radici dobbiamo fare un passo
indietro nel tempo con la rivoluzione
industriale infatti la moda è con lei
anche le cosiddette arti applicate come
la grafica o il design sentivano la
necessità di far capire al consumatore
la differenza tra le proprie creazioni e
i prodotti realizzati in Serie dalle
macchine al fine di giustificare il
prezzo più elevato delle prime
la moda capisce che per rendersi
speciale deve quindi allontanarsi e
offuscare gli aspetti che ha in comune
con l'industria cioè la funzionalità e
il profitto e per contro deve invece
valorizzare ciò che la distingueva
Ovvero la creatività
le belle arti cioè le arti quelle vere
erano perfette per raggiungere questo
scopo sto parlando della poesia della
pittura della scultura la musica il
teatro perché nell'immaginario
collettivo erano considerate prive di
utilità e quindi pure elevate profonde
quasi sacre pensate quanto faceva gola
alla moda Tutto questo perché
accostandosi all'arte lei traeva
beneficio di tutto questo bagaglio
simbolico
Allora adesso Vi propongo altri tre
esempi storici Stavolta che però sono
molto utili per comprendere come questa
intuizione venne sviluppata nel corso
del tempo a volte in maniera virtuosa
altre in maniera più strumentale Ma in
ogni caso innovativa per l'epoca
la stilista Rosa Genoni un personaggio
piuttosto dimenticato dalla storia
Purtroppo
nei primi del Novecento voleva fondare
una Moda Italiana in aperta opposizione
alla dominante Couture francese tanto
che viene ricordata come l'antesignana
del made in Italy Ma come poteva
spostare l'attenzione sulla manifattura
nostrana
richiamando dei suoi abiti l'espressione
del genio italiano per eccellenza ovvero
l'arte rinascimentale ovviamente
cioè quella che nel 500 Aveva reso
l'Italia il centro dell'universo
conosciuto questo abito Infatti si
ispira alla Primavera di Botticelli il
primo
con la seconda immagine invece ci
troviamo di fronte a una vera pietra
miliare della storia del rapporto fra
arte e moda la collaborazione tra la
stilista Elsa Schiaparelli e l'artista
Salvador Dalì la vicinanza di entrambi
al movimento d'avanguardia del
surrealismo ha fatto sì che creassero
delle vere e proprie opere d'arte
indossabili questo abito aragosta
rappresenta la fusione perfetta dei due
loro rispettivi mondi di provenienza
perché in esso c'è innovazione
sperimentazione c'è gioco provocazione
messaggio sociale Qui sì che c'è
l'empowerment femminile perché Guardate
A che altezza del corpo si colloca
l'aragosta
e infine arriviamo al 1965
Yves Allora è in preda ad una crisi
creativa perché ha quasi un mese di
distanza dal lancio della sua nuova
collezione si ritrova senza idee e
quindi apre casualmente un libro su Piet
Mondrian regalatogli dalla madre e sbam
illuminazione
decide di trasformare l'estetica
dell'artista in creazioni sartoriali
cioè né più né meno lui Riporta i quadri
su tessuti inaugurando peraltro una vera
e propria tendenza da parte della moda a
citare la storia dell'arte in chiave pop
questi esempi
sono sono molto utili come vi dicevo per
per capire come l'intuizione è stata
sviluppata ma ci dicono anche un'altra
cosa
ci dicono che l'arte
per per
essere utilizzato così
ha bisogno di un approccio molto
superficiale retinico
questi abiti sono stati depredati
Questo è un problema per tutti noi come
dicono il titolo ci riguarda e ci
riguarda tutti anche coloro a cui la
moda e l'arte non interessano perché
l'incontro di questi due mondi per
funzionare deve attingere al patrimonio
culturale
tra cui l'arte ovviamente e il
patrimonio culturale Come dice il
termine è nostro è di tutti è un'eredità
che c'è stata lasciata e che a nostra
volta lasciamo perché all'interno di
essa si annidano le modalità attraverso
cui le persone prima di noi si sono
organizzate per reagire ai cambiamenti e
quindi nel momento in cui il sistema
dell'arte non salvaguarda questi dati e
il sistema della moda li strumentalizza
è un problema per noi perché stiamo
perdendo informazioni importanti sul
nostro passato ma per il nostro presente
e per il futuro
Non è vero che L'arte è inutile come
dicevo prima non è vero che il
patrimonio culturale È inutile lo dicono
anche molti studi la fruizione culturale
ha dei benefici reali sulla salute umana
Ma non è tutto anche dei benefici
collettivi
questo principio è stato ripreso da un
accordo europeo molto importante entrato
in vigore a partire dal 2011 noto come
convenzione di Faro secondo cui il
patrimonio culturale è uno strumento di
democrazia una risorsa civica
fondamentale che ci permette attraverso
il dialogo l'empatia e la coesione di
affrontare meglio le sfide della
contemporaneità con effetti sul Medio e
lungo termine sulla vita quotidiana di
ognuno di noi
ogni volta che lasciamo che qualcuno o
qualcosa sfrutti il patrimonio culturale
come un pozzo petrolifero una metafora
purtroppo ancora abusata dalla politica
italiana noi quindi non soltanto stiamo
perdendo un'opportunità di crescita ma
stiamo anche depredando la nostra
identità
ad esempio io ballo La Pizzica Salentina
a livello amatoriale ci tengo così tanto
che l'ho anche scritto sulla Bio di
questo Talk e la pizzica che si balla
oggi non è la pizzica che si ballava a
60 anni fa nelle campagne è evidente
Perché nel frattempo la società è
cambiata e quindi anche la danza che
balliamo oggi rispecchia rapporti umani
e dinamiche sociali diverse ma è una
danza che non dimentica Da dove viene
non dimentica le proprie origini
forse la moda dovrebbe fare come la
pizzica dovrebbe aggiungere significati
anziché toglierne e l'arte dovrebbe
raccontarsi anziché prestarsi la
stratificazione è ciò che tiene in vita
la tradizione
Ma quindi visto che la cosa ci riguarda
Cosa possiamo fare noi per evitare che
questo saccheggio continui per
contribuire ad un inversione di rotta
chiederci perché
ogni volta che siamo davanti ad un'opera
d'arte ad una mostra in un museo non
Accontentiamoci di quello che l'occhio
capta Ma andiamo oltre chiediamoci
perché quell'opera è stata fatta e
perché è stata fatta proprio in quel
modo perché la risposta a queste domande
ci offre informazioni importanti per la
nostra quotidianità
stringendo un legame così stretto con il
patrimonio culturale tutti noi saremo
molto meno Clementi nel vederne
storpiati e privatizzati i significati e
il sistema dell'arte e della moda se
vogliono sopravvivere nel mercato
saranno obbligati ad adeguarsi
quindi
svestiamo i panni del consumatore ideale
e Indossiamo quelli dell'individuo
consapevole perché questo è il regalo
più grande che possiamo fare a noi
stessi
[Applauso]
[Musica]